now you know holidays and hosting they
go hand in hand so back to share some
holiday must-have as entertaining expert
Paul Zahn thanks to TaylorMade
productions for sponsoring this segment
Paul welcome back thanks for having me
I'm loving this fall look thank you
let's get into some fall drinks a
delicious pairing of some apple pie and
whiskey oh my gosh we have a delicious
apple pie here and then we have some
Knob Creek bourbon so Knob Creek was
created by Booker no who's an icon in
the spirits industry who wanted to
create a bourbon that hearkened back to
pre-prohibition era bourbon so we
created Knob Creek aged in American Oak
for that nice toasted almond that goes
perfectly with the apple pie how they
feel then we have some rye we have some
Knob Creek ride so that's got a little
bit more spice to it so that could make
a nice Manhattan or everything like that
so again show up to any holiday party
with this pairing and you'll win you'll
win people absolutely yes show up with a
drink and apple pie for me and I'm
definitely your friend are you hosting
friendsgiving at all hopefully hopefully
I haven't planned again all right what's
next what's next next up we have a
wonderful item here from Blissey so
blissy is a pillowcase that is a game
change or pick it up it is 100 Mulberry
silk it's like butter so it's
hypoallergenic it's cooling it's going
to help with the hair it's going to help
with wrinkles it's super soft and we
have a dream set here so the dream set
has a skinny scrunchie a regular
scrunchie and eye mask so you can sleep
in in a pillowcase and then we have the
pillowcase 80 000 um verified review
five star reviews on this one so this is
a great gift for I don't know maybe a
co-host on Las Vegas now
I know blissy very well and like you
said it's great for the hair like bottom
natural hair yeah it's like yeah silk
pillow okay next up we have a spiked
stocking stuffer with some on the Rocks
cocktail so on the rock stars premium
craft cocktails made by some of the top
mixologists around the country and we
have the espresso Martini because it is
that time of year so um
it's everybody's loving this everyone's
loving me espresso martini and they also
have my Thai old-fashioned they have so
many different on the Rocks cocktails
that are perfect to show up to a soiree
that's what do you think this idea this
is cute very chic easy you just shake it
and pour it into a glass and voila
espresso martini and then from Chic to
tart yeah
again if you show up to any holiday
Soiree with a bottle of Patron Silver
people are going to love you so we know
Patron is the world's first Ultra
Premium a tequila it's made 100 blue
Weber Agave whether you're doing a
pomegranate margarita an apple cider
Margarita it's the perfect tequila for
that it has that wonderful roasted um
agave with a little Citrus and peppery
on the end and it's absolutely delicious
and they also have Alto Patron now which
is like their Prestige tequila it's
extra and yellow with a little Reposado
and a little more Anejo and it's like
you know luxury in a glass we love that
I love listening to you talk about these
things you know you know and also means
the heights yeah because the Drone grows
there Agave at the highest points on
Jalisco Mexico so get that nice sweet
Agave see I'm just giving you all the
spirit technology do you should you just
go ahead and create your own no do you
have all this knowledge maybe maybe
will you partner with me uh yeah okay we
got this we got this online as long as I
can take the silk pillow we'll need to
sleep we'll need to sleep so we'll have
the boys where can people find you and
get more information you can follow me
on Instagram thank you Paul it's always
a pleasure having you couldn't all send
it to you